let's go to Jonathan from Ohio Jonathan
from Ohio welcome to the program uh what
can I do for you today what's on your
mind
oh boy Jonathan from Ohio please select
the correct audio device so that we can
hear you
and last chance for Jonathan from Ohio
um can you hear me now I can hear you
sir hello sir how are you thank you for
taking my call my pleasure um this is
more can you hear me I can hear you
okay
uh this is more
um something that happened in Ohio that
I would like to make people aware of
okay
um
so apparently they defined natural gas
as a clean energy source now oh really
so in Ohio it's defined as
clean energy similar to other types of
renewable energy and I just wanted to
make people aware of that
yeah this just happens so for people who
don't know new law signed into uh signed
in by Governor Mike dewine designates
natural gas as green energy that is
absolutely insane and I guess the point
of it um you tell me Jonathan you might
know more about it it paves the way to
Fast Track drilling of oil and gas in
state parks
that's correct oh we're actually working
yeah I work in the natural gas industry
um and there is a lot of fields like in
the eastern part of the State uh that
they're trying to get to so it does it's
really bad for like climate change
obviously yeah and they're trying to set
a standard for other states to to do
this kind of thing and I just think
people should be aware of this and not
let it go down the slippery slope yeah
like burning natural gas is not green
that I hope people understand that now
Jonathan you work in an industry that
you think is bad for the environment it
sounds like
yes I mean like it's like the safety
side of it to make sure people you know
they don't leak or yeah you know events
don't occur so I'm on that side of it
but um
My Hope Is that the industry migrates to
Renewables like my company at least is
trying to do that but
I just thought it was good information
to be aware of 100 yeah I mean it's when
you when we think about renewable and
green
it is certainly not natural gas I
appreciate you bringing it to my
attention Jonathan
yeah for sure all right Jonathan from
Ohio delivering some unfortunately
depressing news